For what is it not able to do coffee animals, it does not get good results from so-keyed
bats, epsom salts.
What are other methods of detoxification that you recommend dealing with live disease
and the hormonal positive breast cancer?
Well, other methods of detoxification.
So I know we have it in our mind that I need to detoxify, so therefore I need to do a detox
or do a therapy that will aid in my detox.
While there's truth in those statements, we have to understand that you are detoxifying.
If you're not detoxifying, you're going to be dead, so you are detoxified, so go back
to that course.
That's why I created that course, the seven phases of detoxification, so you could understand
what detoxification is.
There's a lot of half-truths out there, and this is why I'm so against Instagram influencers
and TikTokers and all this stuff because they're just trying to get likes and shares and
that's how they make money, so they're just feeding with half-truths.
But unfortunately throughout the decades there's a lot of practitioners that, okay, we're
going to put you on a detox because you need the detox, so we're going to put you on a
detox.
Well, that's partially true, but understand, you are already on a detox.
You are detoxing constantly, so it's not we're going to put you on a detox, let's just start
using correct verbiage.
We're going to support detoxification, so, okay, that's better.
But understand, the reason why I made wrote the book and put the course together, the
seven phases of detoxification is you have to do things in order, so like the question
that was asked before, this person's been constipated for nine months, it has not been
doing anything about it.
You're totally ignoring the benefits that you have by looking at the seven phases of detoxification,
you're going to see the first step in detoxification is that you have to be eliminated.
You start with the phase six of detoxification, if you are not having good, solid ball movements
and emptying and cleaning out your gut on a daily basis, you're poisoning yourself, period.
Don't forget it, you have no business doing anything else.
You have no business trying to key laid things out of your body, you have no business, I'm
going to support my gallbladder, you have no business, I really need some liver support.
I need to do this detox if you're not having ball movements, you start with phase six, go
to phase five, you go to phase four, then three, two, one, and then you start doing phase
zero, which is pulling stuff out of the tissue.
So just go back to the seven phases of detoxification, understand that pathway, if you're having really
good ball movements, every single day, then you can go back and start doing some of those
other things, make sure you're taking the binder, supporting gallbladder function, putting
hot packs, castorial packs over your liver, helping, you know, I already have you probably
on things for phase one, two, and three in the liver, and then you can start doing key
laid things out of the body.
You are detoxifying, so, you know, and the biggest reason why a person is not or has got slowed
to detoxification is they're not really dealing with gut issues, so they're not really
emptying their balls on a daily basis.
If you're not doing that, there's things to help you, I mean, you could go on Cape Aloe,
you could go on, you know, if you can't do coffee enemies, you're just making sure that
you're emptying out.
The purpose of coffee enemies is to just sort of move your balls, the purpose of coffee
enemies is to stimulate your parasympathetics.
And if you want to know how to stimulate the parasympathetics without doing coffee enemies,
go to the member site, look at the whole section on parasympathetic, sympathetic balance.
Go to the blog post and look up parasympathetic, and you'll see you could download some BDF
forums on how to stimulate your parasympathetics and how to call me or sympathetic.
There's a whole bunch of different neurological exercises one could do that go beyond coffee
enemies.
So that's the neurological side of detoxification, go back to the course, the seven phases
of detoxification and go through that again, that's going to be your best bet.